You might not recognize Amber Heard as Mera
in Aquaman.
That bright red hair isn't her usual look,
for one thing.
Most of the time she's blonde, and looks much
less like a warrior mermaid.
Let's take a look at the major stepping stones
in Amber Heard's career.
Heard was still in her teens when North Country
came out in 2005, and she wasn't featured
in any of the ads or trailers.
The focus of the film was Charlize Theron,
who plays Josey Aimes, a female iron miner
who takes a stand against sexual harassment.
A young Amber Heard plays the teenage Josey
in some disturbing flashbacks.
Heard makes an impression here, despite her
lack of screentime.
She looks enough like Charlize Theron to believably
play a younger version of the same character,
but she's also already a strong actress in
her own right, delivering an effective performance
in some difficult-to-watch scenes.
Heard was the female lead in Hidden Palms,
a 2007 CW series from Kevin Williamson, creator
of Dawson's Creek.
The show was a teen drama about dark secrets
lurking underneath the sun-drenched surface
of an affluent Palm Springs neighborhood.
Heard played Greta, the mysterious girl next
door who's immediately fascinating to the
series lead, but who's also at the center
of several local mysteries.
The series received a summer order of eight
initial episodes, and was canceled due to
low ratings by the time all eight had aired.
It's largely forgotten today, but it did raise
Amber Heard's profile enough to help her launch
her film career, which no doubt benefited
from this show ending too soon for her to
be tied to it.
Never Back Down was a teen movie about mixed
martial arts fighting, which probably seemed
like a really good idea in 2008.
"Those look kind of cute on you."
"Eww...
They're still sweaty."
It's an extremely by-the-book plot, in which
a teenage boy at a new school must learn to
be the best MMA fighter in order to defeat
a bully and prove himself to all the other
kids.
However, Amber Heard had plenty to do as the
female lead of the movie.
She starts out as the girlfriend of the MMA-fighting
bully, who tricks the protagonist into a fight
he's not ready for.
Even in a largely unmemorable movie, it was
a showy role for a young actress like Heard,
and it helped launch her into bigger and better
parts.
Pineapple Express, coming right on the heels
of Never Back Down, was the movie that really
made Amber Heard a star.
She plays a high school senior in an ill-advised
relationship with the movie's stoner process
server hero, played by Seth Rogen.
Produced by Judd Apatow and directed by indie
darling David Gordon Green, Pineapple Express
was both a hit and a much-discussed comedy
of 2008.
Rogen and co-star James Franco were already
big stars, but it took at least three people's
careers to the next level: Green himself,
supporting player Danny McBride, and of course
rising ingenue Amber Heard.
Heard had only one scene in the 2009 post-apocalyptic
horror comedy Zombieland, but it was one of
the most memorable in the movie.
Jesse Eisenberg's Columbus explains how he
became aware of the zombie plague when his
attractive next door neighbor, played by Heard,
sought refuge in his apartment after being
attacked by what she thought was a crazed
homeless man trying to bite her.
Naturally, Eisenberg wakes the next morning
to find that Heard has become a zombie.
The whole point of her character here is that
she's a basic hot girl who turns into a monster,
but Heard still somehow takes that premise
and makes it charming, and pretty scary:
In 2011 Heard returned to TV, but found no
more success this time around than she did
with Hidden Palms.
The Playboy Club was at least splashier to
start with, a historical drama for NBC about
the women working at the original Playboy
Club in 1961 Chicago.
Heard played Maureen, a young woman who becomes
a Playboy Bunny shortly after arriving in
the city on the run from a dark past.
The nature of Maureen's past was never explored,
as it turns out, because The Playboy Club
was cancelled after only three episodes.
The Rum Diary is another example of Heard
taking a pretty typical "hot girl" part and
making it her own.
This 2011 film by Bruce Robinson was based
on a Hunter S. Thompson book and stars Johnny
Depp as a down-on-his-luck writer who takes
a job in San Juan, Puerto Rico during the
early 1960s.
Heard plays a girl he meets while he's in
a boat and she's skinny-dipping, and she goes
off to become the center of a love triangle
between him and a shady realtor played by
Aaron Eckhart.
The Rum Diary is how Heard and Depp first
met, leading to a relationship that started
in 2012, became a marriage in 2015, and ended
in 2016 with Heard filing for divorce and
accusing Depp of domestic abuse.
All the Boys Love Mandy Lane is a slasher-style
horror movie about an unusual high school
girl, and the secrets she does her best to
keep as the other teens around her start dying.
Heard played the title role, and it might
have been her breakout part if the movie had
come out as originally planned.
It was filmed in 2006, before almost everything
else on this list, with a 20-year-old Heard
perfectly cast as the mysterious Mandy.
Unfortunately, the Weinstein Company declined
to distribute it, and the company they handed
it off to went out of business.
The movie went unreleased in the United States
for seven years, before finally coming out
on video in 2013, after Amber Heard was enough
of a star to get people to watch it.
The sequel to 2010's Machete was not a success
at the box office or among critics, but it
was the kind of sequel that made sense for
the over-the-top character played by Danny
Trejo and the unique sensibility of director
Robert Rodriguez.
The supporting cast of Machete Kills features
a parade of beautiful women.
Amber Heard is still a standout, however.
She plays Blanca Vasquez, a beauty queen who's
also a secret agent and Machete's handler
on his mission to stop a madman from launching
a nuclear missile at Washington, D.C.
Interestingly, Amber Heard plays a glamorous
government assassin again in 2014's 3 Days
To Kill, but in a slightly less outrageous
context.
The film stars Kevin Costner as a veteran
CIA agent with an estranged family and terminal
cancer.
Heard's younger and more ruthless agent is
tasked with manipulating him into hunting
down one last target by offering him an experimental
cure for his illness.
3 Days To Kill is one of those "Aging Baby
Boomer" action movies, where an older man
proves that he still has what it takes to
get the job done.
Thankfully, unlike some movies of this type,
the protagonist's focus remains on his family,
meaning that Heard is never asked to be a
May/December love interest for Costner.
2015's Magic Mike XXL was a phenomenon, far
more so than the original Magic Mike.
The first movie was a drama about male strippers,
whereas the sequel was a feel-good celebration
of male strippers, which unsurprisingly made
it a huge hit among women, as well as gay
men and pretty much anyone who's comfortable
watching muscular men dance with their shirts
off.
Amber Heard was one of many fresh cast members
to join for the sequel, playing a new love
interest for Magic Mike, played by Channing
Tatum.
At first her photographer character seems
likely to be a one-night stand, but after
she and Mike mutually decide not to have sex,
she shows back up later in the movie and they
build more of a relationship.
One thing that's clear in looking back at
Amber Heard's career so far is that she's
obviously been chosen for many roles because
of how beautiful she is.
However, as we've seen again and again, what
makes her interesting in those roles is the
intelligence she always displays, adding depth
to characters who weren't necessarily created
to have any.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the DC
Extended Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.